[Music]
I wish uh I want you to hear from Sally
Reaganhart lost her 28-year-old son
Christian. I want to run a two-minute
clip. Several months ago, I was
interviewed uh by a PBS show called
Religion and Ethics News
Weekly. I lost my only
son, firefighter Christian Reaganhard,
on
911. He had only graduated from the fire
academy six weeks before
911. Before that, he served his country
in the United States
Marines. He was a recon sergeant. And if
there's any Marines in the audience, you
know what that
means. Just like Roselene's brother,
Shawn, he was a Marine. There were many
Marines and many members of the armed
forces who were lost on 911.
I'm here today to thank this
conservative group for allowing us to
come and speak the truth. When we first
learned that there would be a mosque and
cultural center erected near 911, we
were in a state of shock. We could not
believe it.
My son Christian at age
28 is one of
the,00 victims who have never been
recovered. I heard for the first time
today this
heartbreaking autopsy
report that I've never heard it before.
And I want to thank the Talon family for
sharing this because the American public
has to know what really happened there.
The devastation and destruction. We had
a system that wanted to absolutely
suppress the horror. And in every way
the truth was suppressed. the horror,
the agony, the lack of preparedness, the
lack of planning, the lack of attention
to past terrorist attacks that had
occurred on the USS Cole, on the Marine
barracks, and in so many other
instances. When we heard that a mosque
was to be constructed so close to the
sacred
ground, keeping in mind that 40% of the
uniformed services and
40% of all the victims were never
recovered. What that means is that their
human remains were scattered at such an
enormous
trajectory miles and
miles around ground
zero. Just to think that in this
country, this beautiful country that my
parents also Irish
immigrants came to and worked so
dutifully during the
years, raised, myself and my
sister and my son and daughter who are
so much like my grandparents. so
dutifyful, so decent, so committed to
this country and so dedicated to the
people of New York City. To think that
people like them and that the sons of of
the people here with us
today remain scattered in the earth.
It it is such a a heartbreaking thing to
realize
and we are still those of us 40% of
people we're still looking for the
1100 victims that were lost some
semblance but we know now that that will
never happen but the least that what
we're asking for and what we asked for
the people for from the Cordoba
initiative
from the Iman and Daisy Khan. What we
ask them for is
sensitivity. We want sensitivity for the
sacred ground. We want sensitivity for
our loss. My son was one of the most
liberal and tolerant people. Liberal in
the respect that he respected all
people. He respected all religions. in
the Marine
Corps. He traveled all through the
Middle East. He brought back artifacts
from the Middle East, a Persian rug, and
all so many other things. He loved
people. But in this terror terrorist
attack which was the great which had the
greatest loss of life on American soil
since the civil war. This attack that
was orchestrated by demonic caved
dwelling
barbarians who
could who considered my loving son and
the loving children of all the
victims considered them infidels. My son
is an angel who was murdered by demons.
I'm sorry that we weren't able to see
the film. That's what I said on this PBS
show. It showed both sides of the issue,
but I have to say
that nothing rings so true as the
request of the families for sensitivity.
give us the same sensitivity and
tolerance that these people are asking
for at ground zero. In conclusion, I
would like to say
that with two exceptions, we have been
so thoroughly disappointed and rejected
by all the elected officials in New York
City with two outstanding exceptions.
One of them is here with us today, New
York City Councilman from Queens, Dan
Howerin. I want to thank you for your
stand as being the only city councilman
in New York City to stand up for the
sensitivities of the
families. Thank you. Thank you very
much.
And the and the other person is our
wonderful Congressman Peter
King. I cannot express the gratitude of
the 911 families. These people risk
everything to stand up for what is
right. the families of the victims will
never be silent. We also want to thank
the Conservative Party and we want to
thank above all Pamela Geller and her
organization. Without her, we would
never have a
voice. Thank you again and we ask for
your support. We need your help. We need
the help of other congressmen and other
elected officials that we haven't been
able to meet as yet. Please support us.
We need your help. God bless you for
coming today and for listening to us.
Thank you.
I also want to mention Lario Pantano
who's in the audience who spoke at our
rally. This has to be a campaign issue
because you know it's bigger than the
mosque. You know it's a national
security issue. I'm hoping we have time.
We're running late that we'll be able to
hear from Allario Pentano. Allar, are
you here? He's right here. Support this
man's campaign in North Carolina.
Uh, I think Daniel, because he was the
only politician, New York City
councilman, if you can give us some
brief remarks. Um, and I saw you at the
Walmart hearing. You were
brilliant. I mean, talk about a den of
cavemen. Um, you were amazing. Oh my
god, what Neanderthalss.